i feel like it's come to a point where
we can just all agree and say plainly
that simple is the undisputed goat of cs
go be really rough or simple to actually
get through this he's going to throw the
awp oh my god simple why is happening
he's going to free up off of that more
than likely too there's a good shot from
simple to shut up fallen down to a two v
three and another one from simple he's
even got another player sitting back
over here in the t-rex the nade is gonna
push him back but on the repeat simple
is just getting these kills
that he even gets the fourth one as well
he needs a multi-kill first found twist
aggressing they have to double peak he's
getting his shots he's hitting it
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again he's the perfect
player he can rifle he can op he can
pistol he can deagle he's a great
utility player i mean there aren't many
things that simple can't do but what if
i told you that the best counter-strike
player in the entire world actually has
some of the worst crosshair placement
ever seen from a professional player so
how is it that simple is able to
dominate the world of cs when he hasn't
even been able to master one of the
game's most basic principles
and on that note
is crosshair placement as important
as everyone says it is
[Applause]
alright so before we get into the video
make sure you pre-fire the like button
subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications i'm sorry that
was really cringe just
just do the it's youtube just do the
thing all right so if you have ever
touched a competitive shooter there's a
very good chance that you've heard this
term used before
cross hair placement the idea is that as
long as you're aiming at head level
you'll have a better chance of killing
your opponent as they step into your
view now for most players playing on lan
allows you to hold angles that you would
otherwise struggle to online and if your
crosshair placement is good enough then
all you really need to do is just wait
for your opponent to step into your
sight and click on their head players
who use low sensitivities like brax nico
and naf are known for their exquisite
crosshair placement they've been
incredibly successful throughout the
years by relying on clicking their mouse
just as their opponent turns a corner
but brax in particular is known to have
some of the best crosshair placement in
the history of fps you see brax doesn't
just hold the very edge of an angle like
you see here he kicks his crosshair out
a little bit many players will hold an
angle too tightly and then get
dumpstered when someone wide swings them
but not brax and if you play valorant a
game in which holding angles is quite
weak
you probably deal with the [ __ ] every
day seconds left
oh my
that was a [ __ ] lamborghini but as
launders illustrated beautifully back in
2017
brax always used to leave a little bit
of wiggle room to account for the wide
swing remember the key factor in getting
this kill efficiently is visualizing
where your opponent will be when they
come into your angle so i hold it nice
and wide and doesn't need to flick the
distance that he holds it from the angle
allows him to react accordingly removing
the need to flick means reducing
randomness a debilitated toddler with no
motor skills can hit this shot in his
sleep and that's the point you're
reducing the amount of times you have to
flick and you can never rely on your
flick shots for 100 accuracy now let's
take a look at the homie xiwu many
people myself included believe that this
french superstar plays perfect
counter-strike every aspect of his game
is virtually flawless especially his
crosshair placement
now let's slow that clip down if you
look closely at zyu's crosshair you can
see that he barely has to move his mouse
at all to secure these frags every time
he peaks an angle he's already aiming at
head height so he only needs to adjust
his crosshair on a horizontal axis but
how important is it to have god-like
cross-hair placement like zywoo well to
help us find out we reached out to dr
madison klarkowski a professor of
computer science at the university of
saskatchewan who specializes in computer
human interaction and she explained that
for the average fps player crosshairs
are crucial we know that crosshairs are
an important player aid they they
represent a central fixation point for
attracting visual attention to a desired
region i mean they're even used in
experimental research you um use
crosshairs
in perception tests for example or
attention tests to make sure a
participant or encourage a participant
to look at a stimulus and to prevent
gaze drift um
the other obvious benefit in first
person shooters is that it actually lets
players conceptualize where their
bullets are going to go and yet for
years simple the greatest cs go player
to ever live has been criticized for his
rather low crosshair placement nobody
understands how this dude's able to take
over so many matches when he spends so
much of his time aiming near the ground
hey stop losing rounds dude you keep
talking to me shut up you suck you aim
at the ground when you run around you're
so bad you need a tan get some friends
but simple isn't like every other player
pre-aiming at his enemies heads would
just
make things too easy instead he relies
on his flicks snapping to his enemies
heads with ease and at this point it's
just part of his play style you see
simple plays on a
pretty high sensitivity like high enough
that it's hard to even comprehend how he
manages to stay so damn consistent with
an edpi of 1236
which is roughly
33.6 centimeters per 360. simple
sensitivity is way higher than the
average counter-strike player
but he makes it work anyways in fact it
makes his performances
all the more impressive i i'm sure i
don't have to tell you but like
the dudes the dude has hit some pretty
nutty flicks over the years
now of course simple isn't the only
player who's ever used an absurdly high
sensitivity and found success plenty of
other competitors are known for having
ridiculous edpies but none of them have
been able to reach the same level of
consistency as the goat you see double
smokes in the same place there simple
just jumping casually into the side he's
going to fall down again
what is this place from simple are you
serious what is that you can't do that
simple that's not allowed this is not
fpl this is a major
so how in the hell does he aim like this
day in and day out well like most high
sense players simple is a wrist aimer
and what that means is that rather than
moving his entire arm to control his
mouse he opts to just strictly move his
wrist now for many gamers aiming solely
with your wrist can actually be a little
dangerous if you don't know what you're
doing but why is that
well now we will turn to my sweet supple
supple-wristed controller-meaning friend
colton for an explanation
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about presented by amd
that's right a big thanks goes out to
amd especially for making that slick new
ryzen 9 5950x that i'm using
the company that brought you radeon
graphics is back to partner with us and
further drive a wedge between dimitri
and i until our rivalry bursts in one
serious fps 1v1 forever altering a
friendship born on the battlefields of
over-explained skits
first and foremost i'm not an expert in
ergonomics and i'm definitely not a
doctor if you have any pain in your
wrists i recommend talking to somebody
with a medical license who can help you
with those before they become serious
problems
ultimately don't take anything i'm about
to say as medical advice cool
cool speaking of experts in ergonomics
we've actually had the chance to sit
down with one to talk about keyboard and
sitting positions so if you want some
more ergo content you should go check
that video out as well now excessive
flicking with your mouse hand especially
when partnered with less than ideal
posture can put unnecessary strain on
your muscles tendons and ligaments it
can cause some discomfort if not handled
properly and in more extreme cases it
can even cause long-term injuries we've
seen plenty of professional players take
breaks due to wrist injuries but not all
wrist issues are created equal so
without going into a full anatomy lesson
on the wrists since i never took anatomy
let's take a quick look at some examples
and how they can impact gamers first
let's take a look at the ligaments the
tissue that connects the different bones
in your wrist together when you sprain
your wrists this is the tissue that's
either been overstretched or torn
injuring these ligaments generally takes
some more serious impacting or twisting
force so without some really bad posture
and extended gaming hours you aren't
likely to injure the ligaments in your
wrist the piece that lies at the core of
this video are the tendons specifically
your extensor tendons that are
responsible for bending your wrist back
and most importantly for us bending your
wrist in the direction of your thumb and
pinky finger these are the tendons doing
most of the work when simple flicks
mouse around destroying someone peaking
an angle they're also the dangerous part
about being a wrist aimer overusing
these tendons can lead to a whole host
of issues that will definitely inhibit
one's ability to frag out carpal tunnel
which you've almost certainly heard
about can be caused by swelling in these
tendons putting pressure on the median
nerve running through your wrist not fun
the answer proper stretching rest and
ice if you're a really serious gamer
want more specifics well again i'm not a
doctor so go find one of those now all
that said there are other factors that
affect the ergonomics of your gaming
posture fps veteran ron rambo kim noted
back in 2019 that simple sitting
position might actually play a big role
in how he aims you can see that he does
have most his forum on the table
and it's very
level or horizontal with the table it's
like flat right
and then also notice how close his chest
is to the table
and because he has most of forearm on
the table and in order to have support a
decent posture with that forearm
position the closer you sit to the table
the better you are for your back so for
example if he was far away from the
table and he had that same forearm
position
in order to keep that you'd have to lean
forward and slouch forward and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about presented by amd rambo
also goes on to note just how wide
simple spreads his arms across his desk
his arms are positioned much more
symmetrically than most players which
allows him to play more comfortably but
the most important thing that rambo
talks about in his video is with respect
to simple's training methods
it's fair to say that nobody can flick
with the op as well as simple and when
you watch him train
it's pretty obvious why the thing i want
you to pay attention to now
is
how well he's able to flick his op
in every direction so
up down left to right right to left
in every
verticality and horizontally every
combination of either or
and he's doing this because
this is the kind of motion that he's
going to be using in a match
because of his play style
he's one of those players that like to
get up close to people
take map control and push the pace he's
not a passive opera
so he's practicing the mechanics and
feels that he would use in a match
so again simple is not a passive opera
no my boy likes to get down dirty in
your face and just dumpster you before
you can even begin to comprehend what
just happened and this in-your-face
playstyle actually plays a huge role
when it comes to offsetting his poor
crosshair placement like if he was a
super defensive opera who just sat
around holding angles all day then sure
it would make sense for him to really
focus on tightening up his pre-aim a
little bit but when you're running
around the map with his shotgun style of
opping then crosshair placement just
isn't as important his mastery of
flicking allows him to make minute
adjustments on the fly with ease and a
huge reason why is that the pivot point
on his wrist is always the same purely
speculatively
it could be that his poor crosshair
placement is actually beneficial to
simple
so because he has that higher
sensitivity because he has more of a
flicky playstyle he has to adjust
further to hit a target so that might
actually you know having that or
crosshair placement that's not just you
know a millimeter away from where the
enemy's going up here may actually
benefit him because he does flick and he
does have that high sensitivity so it
might be that needing to move the
crosshair over longer distances is a
more appropriate um strategy for him
he's perfected his flicks in such a way
that he never hyper extends the joint he
knows exactly how far he can move his
wrist before resetting it back to its
original position so is crosshair
placement the most important thing to
focus on when learning attack shooter
well
i mean look every player is different
and there's no real correct definitive
answer but
honestly
yes
playing on a lower sensitivity and
pre-aiming at head level will almost
certainly allow you to be more
consistent but for the rare breed of
high sense superstars like simple
it's not that big of a deal i would say
that you know it's very possible that
for someone with simple strength and his
preferred play style that that increased
sensitivity and that the flickiness
um the crosshair placement is
potentially less important what we
understand about crosshair placement and
what we understand about good crosshair
placement is informed by the majority so
it might be that what we perceive as
poor cross hair placement isn't actually
poor crosshair placement for that player
but you'll have to put in the hours
become accustomed to your own limits
and decide for yourself
well thankfully my sweet
supple wristed controller maning friend
colton is here to explain
rip you dude absolutely rip you what
would we do if i didn't just think of
these you know off the top my head you
know
what would we do what would we do with
each other yeah exactly right like have
a thriving friendship yeah exactly
that's that's super boring that's
overrated yeah yeah yeah
now we go
my game just froze
what the [ __ ]
oh yeah hello
counter strike